back in the u.s american air travel is
making a comeback this memorial day
weekend
60 more americans are expected to travel
compared to this time last year the
airline industry is also expanding
two new carriers have launched during
the pandemic errol burnett has more
if you're one of the more than 37
million americans expected to travel
this memorial day weekend
you now have a few new cost-effective
options at your disposal
19 flight doesn't really get any cheaper
than that
we're trying to go out there and give
customers choice that's how ceo andrew
levy is boosting demand for his new
low-cost airline we have wonderful
people great low fares and
we're just excited to be out in the
marketplace avilo's hub is based in
burbank california
and currently services 11 small airports
including arcata eureka california grand
junction colorado
and bozeman yellowstone montana there
may be other
ways to get to these airports in the
western u.s maybe through lax
maybe through a connection but we're
trying to offer something that's
different to the customer to the
traveling public
and it's already expanding with a second
hub opening in new haven connecticut
last year due to the pandemic the
airline industry suffered more than 370
billion dollars in losses
that led boeing's ceo to declare at
least one airline would be pushed out of
business
instead two new ones sprung up a velo
and breeze airways
with goals to tackle smaller airports
across the country
by the middle of the summer we'll be in
15 cities
breeze ceo david nealerman is also
testing a new market welcome to breeze
everybody
95 of the routes on its network have new
non-stop
service including from hartford to
columbus and providence to pittsburgh
its fares run as low as 39
the u.s airline industry is recovering
it is recovering faster
and better than many expected henry
hardeville is an airline travel analyst
and says these new airlines
will help drive competition making
flying better for the consumer
these are both budget focused airlines
which means they'll bring
more low fare seats to more communities
and that helps make air travel more
accessible and affordable for everybody
now while this upcoming weekend is a
boon for these smaller airlines there is
an
open question as to if there are enough
air travelers to sustain them
long term the last u.s airline to launch
virgin america folded
back in 2018 and according to the faa
conflict in the skies is
on the rise and these low-cost carriers
have to shake that
i don't know that bus in the sky
stereotype but
they offer no frills and gail you get
what you pay for
you know that's your mom always said but
people want to go
someplace errol any place thank you very
much